bonsoir le 7-8 l'actu sur tv fil 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale à
l'actualité des yvelines voici les
titres de ce 22 janvier la croix rouge
intervient également en faveur du
maintien de l'autonomie une action que
le grand public connaît - et dont nous
parlerons avec notre invité jean les
guislain la responsable de la croix
rouge à saint quentin en yvelines le
syndicat alliance police nationale
mobilise est aujourd'hui après une
première action en dedans novembre
dernier le mot d'ordre n'a pas changé
les agents veulent plus de moyens et
puis aversa et des ateliers pour aider
les chômeurs se déroulent chaque mardi
tout au long du mois en février un forum
pour l'emploi viendra conclure cette
mobilisation de la ville et puis en fin
de journal nous y reviendrons aussi sur
l' annonce des investitures pour les
municipales à l'ump et à lutter avec
quelques surprises notamment à maurepas
1964 les beatles débarque en france
encore peu connus ils font leurs débuts
non pas à paris mais à versailles sur la
scène du cirano c'est l'image du jour
l'établissement elle va célébrer le 50e
anniversaire de cet événement comme il
se doit ce soir lever de rideau dans à
peine plus de deux heures si vous nous
suivez en direct et nous allons en
parler encore pendant quelques instants
avec jean luc le gall fric bonsoir
bonsoir jean luc le gall frais et
organisateur de l'événement pour zone
ouest vous êtes en ligne avec nous ce
soir on a du mal à croire que les
beatles commencent leur carrière dans
les yvelines pourquoi versailles et puis
comment un tel événement at il été
possible
jean luc le gall africaine visiblement
on a quelques difficultés à établir la
la communication téléphonique avec lui
on essaiera de la voir un petit peu plus
tard au cours de cette édition pour
revenir sur cet événement des beatles
avec ce concert hommage ce soir pour
l'instant je vous propose de parler à
d'économies dans l'actualité et c'est
toujours à versailles au mois de janvier
au mois de février il y aura cette
opération dédiée à l'emploi avec 400
offres à pourvoir un forum permettra de
rencontrer les recruteurs le 12 février
en attendant des ateliers permettent de
s'y préparer les mardis soirs clark en
biais nous apporte quelques explications
aïcha recherchent un emploi et souhaite
être épaulé dans sa recherche mardi soir
à la maison de quartier près au bois à
versailles elle a découvert cet atelier
de préparation aux entretiens d'embauché
un atelier qui tombe à pic et qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de l'opération
un mois pour l'emploi j'ai déjà un cv
mais bon je voudrais voir par rapport
aux personnes qui sont ici à ce que le
cv est bien fait et en plus on peut
envoyer directement je pense à
l'entreprise donc c'est intéressant pour
moi ça parce que je cherche du travail
et en étant mère de quatre enfants
les entreprises partenaires de
l'événement cherche à recruter ce
recueil regroupe l'ensemble de leurs
offres de postes de l'aide soignante au
chef de projet informatique
les candidats se prépare aujourd'hui à
rencontrer leurs recruteurs lors d'un
forum de l'emploi le 12 février prochain
en fait préparation de cv simulation
d'entretien en même temps je peux quand
on travaille sur un cv on peut
travailler aussi l'entretien d'une
certaine façon après c'est quand même
très limité parce que travailler un cv
une lettre de candidature et puis un
entretien ça prend normalement
beaucoup de temps voilà donc on essaie
de surtout de faire le lien entre ce qui
sera proposé le jour du forum est ce que
les personnes recherchent en tant que
cible professionnelle
ce mois pour l'emploi s'adresse en
priorité aux jeunes mais le public
présent dépasse largement cette
catégorie d'âge ce type d'ateliers sera
reconduit tous les mardis soirs jusqu'au
12 février
on
reste dans le domaine économique avec
cette information révélée aujourd'hui
par l'express le ministère des finances
qui soupçonnerait mcdonald's france
d'évasion fiscale le siège de
l'entreprise qui se trouve à guyancourt
auraient été perquisitionnés le 15
octobre dernier selon le magazine depuis
2009 plus de 2 milliards d'euros
auraient transité via les filiales
luxembourgeoises et genève was sent que
la tva et l'impôt sur les bénéfices ne
soit versée manque à gagner pour l'état
de 330 à 650 millions d'euros mcdonald's
refuse réfute les accusations les
accusations mais confirme la tenue en
octobre dernier d'une demande
d'informations de l'inspection des
finances publiques au siège de
l'entreprise à guyancourt donc il
s'agissait cependant d'une procédure de
contrôle régulières selon la direction
le syndicat de police alliance qui
mobilise à nouveau ses agents 6000
policiers se sont retrouvés le 13
novembre dernier devant l'assemblée
nationale pour dénoncer leurs conditions
de vie et de travail devant l'absence de
changement des actions ont été menées
aujourd'hui devant toute la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
ici à viroflay ou encore à evry cergy et
melun était évoquée harcèlement moral
stigmatisation pression sur les
objectifs ou encore manque de moyens
dans la ligne de mire des syndicats
méthode managériale conditions de
travail restrictions budgétaires une
manifestation nationale et unitaire pour
être aussi être rapidement organisé vous
avez souvent des patrouilles qui sont à
amener à patrouiller avec un adjoint de
sécurité est un titulaire donc un manque
de sécurité certaines vous avez des
patrouilles qu'ils sont obligés de se
transporter sur d'autres communes parce
que manque de d'effectifs sur les autres
circonscriptions de police donc c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai casse-tête au
quotidien pour assurer correctement la
sécurité de nos concitoyens sur ce
département avec le manque d'effectifs
que l'on a sur dans la police nationale
beaucoup de collègues sont rappelés sur
leur jour de repos ne peuvent pas avoir
leurs jours de congés comme il se doit
et donc viennent travailler sur leurs
jours de repos la réalité c'est qu'il
faudrait débloquer les moyens faire en
sorte que
la modernisation de l'action publique
qui bloque aujourd'hui le nombre de gens
qui rentrent en école de police soient
clairement ouvert et que en fait il est
davantage de recrutement et surtout des
budget adéquat pour pouvoir entretenir
le parc automobile mais aussi les moyens
qui sont utilisés tous les jours les
moyens individuels et collectifs il y a
dans les années 2000 juste pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée huit mille
fonctionnaires de police qui étaient
formés dans les écoles de police
aujourd'hui on peine à remplir les
écoles de police à hauteur de 2500 et
puis autre manifestation ce 22 janvier
celle des lycéens des établissements
sonia delaunay à villepreux et 17 mar à
maurepas devant le rectorat de
versailles ils protestaient contre les
fermetures des filières management mais
aussi la préparation à l'institut de
formation en soins infirmiers la semaine
dernière déjà une action similaire a été
menée les avancées ne sont pas assez
significative selon les délégués
syndicaux est l'invité de cette édition
c'est jean-luc guislain bonsoir mon
soeur vous êtes le responsable de la
croix rouge à saint quentin en yvelines
on va évoquer l'aide à domicile le
soutien à l'autonomie ou encore les
actions halte répit alzheimer la croix
rouge mène aussi ce type d'action on en
parle moins souvent pourtant c'est un
travail fréquents et qui occupe même la
majeure partie des activités au niveau
national déjà
majeure partie non c'est une des
filières métiers de la croix rouge en a
contre elle la croix rousse et 18000 de
salariés quand même dans différents
états dans plus de 6 ans établissements
alors personnes âgées
personnes sont handicapées et maintien à
domicile et aides à domicile
bon je veux pas inondée d'eau
chiffrement fin il ya cinquante six
mille personnes domicile qui sont aidées
par la croix-rouge d'une manière
régulière alors quels sont les justement
l'aide de manière concrète les actions
qui sont menées par la croix rouge
concernant le domaine de la santé et de
l'autonomie par exemple dans le cadre de
l'autonomie une des actions locales
dont vous avez parlé la halte répit pour
les malades alzheimer pour essayer de
ddc les aidants qui sont souvent
laissez un peu seuls chez eux s'occuper
de leurs malades cette halte répit qui
avait géré il n'y a pas très longtemps
ça fait un an donc c'est sûr maurepas il
encore parce que c'est juste en limite
et l'accueil 5,6 malades avec des
bénévoles tous les samedis après midi et
c'est une manière d'aider les aidants de
soulager les aidants dans le cadre de
leur mission qui est très dure près
difficile à maintenir et c'est une des
actions locales que nous avons peut-être
voir quelques images pendant qu'on parle
de cette halte répit est juste vous
laisser aussi repréciser concrètement
comment cela fonctionne à qui cela
s'adresse il faut venir vous voir il a
les héros devient numéro de téléphone à
appeler
bon qui ce que je peux donner 06 15 87
79 75 pour un rendez vous pour faire une
petite estimation de la situation ce
pronom des malades qui ont encore une
certaine autonomie qui encore une
certaine possibilités d'expression et
donc en plus tôt en début de maladie et
ce qui expérience d'une année pour nous
nous démontre que c'était quelque chose
de très important et de très très
enrichissant même pour les bénévoles de
voir que ces personnes malades qui
souvent sont complètement isolés parce
que partir d'un moment nous on est
malade on reste chez soi on ne rencontre
on a plus de socialisation et tout ça le
fait de bénéficier de cette activité
groupe pendant quelques heures ramène le
sourire le calme dans vos chez ces
malades et amène surtout
quelques heures de répit ou de détente
d'où le nom pour les aidants dont les
personnes qui interviennent de la croix
rouge sont des professionnels ils sont
forts mais ce pays ce sont ce sont des
bénévoles que nous avons formés
spécifiquement et qui viennent d'une
manière régulière tous les 2 ou 3 samedi
pour s'occuper de malades dont une demi
douzaine de personnes qui sont
accueillis est ce que ça va monter en
puissance dans les prochains prochains
mois non non en fait en fait la
structure pro pour 6,8 pour l'instant on
est on est plutôt de trois d'ailleurs il
nous reste un peu de place donc
si certains aidants ont besoin que nous
les aidions qu'ils nous passent un coup
de fil et on est en mesure d'accepter
quelques malades supplémentaires l'ordre
a quitté cette action de la croix rouge
que vous menez la halte répit alzheimer
juste pour parler déjà de la philosophie
générale de la croix rouge c'est d'aider
les personnes qui le souhaitent à rester
chez elle les personnes qui sont malades
des personnes en fin de vie c'est la
politique qui est développée à travers
les actions qui sont menées
nationalement c'est une c'est une des
activités parce que bon c'est un nid une
idée importante sur le plan national
c'est qu'une personne qui est habitué à
son son environnement
vit mieux si elle peut rester dans cet
environnement quels que soient ces
conditions de
de santé tant que c'est possible ce
n'est pas toujours possible mais tant
que c'est possible et c'est l'expérience
que toutes les familles peuvent
connaître c'est que dès l'instant où on
sort quelqu'un de son cadre habituel le
dépaysement agit beaucoup sur l'état
mental et l'état physique de la personne
de donc pour ça qu'on essaie de le
retarder le plus possible
l'idée de la croix rousse et lutter
contre toute forme d'exclusion et de est
d'aider les familles ou les personnes
autant qu'elles le peuvent donc c'est
pas que de l'alimentaire c'est pas que
du vestimentaire c'est aussi bondée
halte répit c'est aussi des services
d'aidé à domicile c'est aussi mais c'est
aussi des maisons pour handicapés ou des
maisons de retraite ça c'est mon
agresseur sur la partie saint quentin en
yvelines dans vos activités de préciser
sur l'aide alimentaire vestimentaire est
ce que ça va évoluer aussi oui parce que
en fait je pense que les activités de la
croix rouge sont assez peu connue parce
qu'elles sont très variés et que c'est
très difficile de les faire connaître
alors on connait celles qui sont
développées localement parce que parce
que vous méritez régulièrement donc je
parle des actions que moi je les valeurs
mais par exemple on parle pas que
dans le secteur de deux crèches sont
gérées ou même dans les yvelines trois
ou quatre crèches sont gérées par la
croix rouge parce que nous avons une
filière petite enfance mais sur
saint-quentin en yvelines spécifiquement
vous pourriez avec votre antenne
développer ce genre d'activités oui oui
parce que ben la crèche du crédit
agricole de guyancourt par exemple est
géré par un rouge de 50 ans la crèche de
coignières est géré par la croix rouge
la crèche d'houdan est géré par la croix
rouge donc
oui on est on est toujours en mesure
d'aider une ces panneaux personnellement
qu'ils géreront parce que c'est ce sont
des métiers bien spécifique qui
demandaient des connaissances que moi je
ne réponds aux qualités de président
mais par contre la filière métier de la
croix rouge est tout à fait en mesure
est prête à répondre à des appels
d'offres si c'est nécessaire une action
vous avez développé également depuis la
rentrée c'est cette domiciliation est ce
qu'on peut préciser un peu les choses
oui oui dont on s'est aperçu qu'il
existait de moins en moins de structures
en mesure d'accepter des personnes en
situation de grande précarité
puisqu'il ne dispose même pas d'une
adresse postale donc nous avons mis en
place nous avons eu un arrêté
préfectoral qui est sorti en juillet fin
juillet qui nous autorise maintenant
être prendre la domiciliation de
personnes en sang après sans faire donc
c'est peu des sdf c'est un peu des
migrants une centaine de personnes
aujourd'hui nous avons déjà une centaine
de personnes qui en bénéficient ça a été
ça va très vite plus vite que nous le
pensions mais bon c'est signe qu'il y
avait un besoin spécifique
alors pour financer l'ensemble de ces
actions peut peut-être évoqué l'une des
opérations qui seront menées en
s'affinant spa toutes les actions et
mais cette opération donner vos
sentiments caisse c'est au franprix
d'elancourt pour situer les choses le
dessin pierre mais la crise saint-pierre
les gens vont pouvoir donner un petit
peu plus arrondir leurs
facturations de microdon disons qu'ils
organisaient et dont la croix rouge
bénéficie au franprix de la clé saint
pierre oui les gens ont la possibilité
d'arrondir leur addition
c'était pas vous rendre ça peut mettre
20 ça peut mettre 30 il ya pas de lison
faire de publicité pour l'établissement
n'hésitez pas à vous y rendre hu a
adressé directement vos dons bien sûr à
la croix rouge puisque vous êtes en
plateau juste un dernier amour
concernant l'action très médiatique que
vous menez chaque année ce sont ces
maraudes en période hivernale vous allez
voir ces personnes sans logis sans
domicile fixe quel bilan on peut faire
au milieu de l'hiver
pour l'instant ça se passe relativement
bien nous avons suffisamment de place
pour emmener les toutes les personnes
que l'on peut trouver dans la rue et qui
demande à être hébergée un tout le
demandent pas tout le veulent pas
d'aimer faute ou celle qui accepte que
nous le fassions nous sommes en mesure
de le faire on al en projet l'ouverture
d'un autre centre de dagg d'hébergement
d'urgence sur versailles mais pour
l'instant il est pas ouverts parce
qu'ils aient pas vraiment besoin donc
donc c'est signe que personne ne
couchent dans la rue s'il n'a pas envie
d'y toucher merci d'être venu nous
parler de vos actions aussi bien des
maraudes que les autres actions que vous
menez qu'on connaît maintenant un petit
peu mieux en matière aide à domicile
merci on aura l'occasion de reparler que
ce que tu as fait marcher les 150 ans de
la croix rouge et vous reviendrez sur ce
plateau par les d'ensemble des
événements que vous avez prévu ça
commencera plus tôt vers mars avril on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler sur ce
plateau merci encore à vous on poursuit
ce journal on va parler culture dans un
instant nous parlerons de ce fameux
concert des beatles qui va débuter dans
moins de deux heures à à versailles pour
l'instant juste un mot concernant ce
projet assez original qui est menée par
un étudiant versailles est un étudiant
de l'école d'architecturé une pyramide
de holographique ar cas c'est le nom de
ce projet arc ça permet de créer des
objets en trois dimensions dans l'espace
olivier maniscalco et jonathan vilma là
nous en dise plus
en cinquième année de master à l'école
d'architecturé de versailles vincent
mars à 24 ans tente de révolutionner le
monde de sa profession au départ issu
d'un pari avec un ami vincent se lance
dans un défi fou le projet arc après des
mois de travaux et de nombreuses
améliorations
il met au point une pyramide de verre ou
l'architecte peut modéliser ses plans en
3d grâce à des hologrammes et à l'aide
du logiciel qu'ils mettent au point de
simples mouvements de main et commande
vocale suffisent pour travailler en
architecture en fait on a toujours un
petit problème ça se voit souvent avec
les étudiants et autres c'est que quand
on regarde quelque chose et qu'on le
fait par justement par l'interface de
l'ordinateur cette interface la dénature
l'idée le but c'est d'arriver à refaire
du croquis directement en trois
dimensions à la fois des bâtiments
directement en trois dimensions et pour
arriver limite à un rendu de type
maquette mais à l'intérieur d'une
pyramide en trois dimensions pour en
parler avec le client et comme mieux
communiquer avec lui afin de concevoir
son prototype vincent a déboursé 600
euros et pour le financer il a organisé
une levée de fonds via internet
récoltant le soutien de 73 personnes il
a également créé un site pour
communiquer sur son projet et faire
participer ceux qui le souhaitent au
design de sa pyramide inspiré par les
films de science-fiction hollywoodien
comme iron man vincent souhaiterait
maintenant démocratiser son idée et la
commercialiser au plus grand nombre en
juin il présentera ses professeurs une
version plus aboutie de son projet
50e anniversaire des 50 ans du premier
concert des beatles en france c'était à
versailles je vous le disais tout à
l'heure nous sommes en ligne avec jean
luc le gall fric bonsoir cette fois ci
la liaison téléphonique fonctionne bien
vous êtes organisateur de l'événement
pour zone l'ouest on a du mal à croire
je disais tout à l'heure que les beatles
et commencé leur carrière à dans les
yvelines à versailles comment un tel
événement à l'époque il ya 50 ans a pu
voir le jour kelly l'original
alors les origines en fait à l'époque
les gens du la salle de spectacle le
cyrano parce qu'elle n'est pas insulter
une salle de spectacle et non pas
simplement un cinéma travaillez beaucoup
avec ce qu catherine
comptable de l'olympia aider les
avant-premières de l'olympia au piano
donc il est très régulièrement des
concerts avec ce soir là il ya les
beetle qui était pour le coup un monde
totalement inconnu effet en deuxième
partie de nuit
avec trois paires donc les beatles à
l'époque n'avait pas de notoriété
spécifique en dehors des frontières de
l'angleterre il commenté nom commençait
vraiment à exploser en 63 et l'équipe
est encore un groupe pas très connu mais
pour le pour la victoire bruno coquatrix
les afficher ensuite pendant trois
semaines à l'olympia mettait tous les
noms il a fait sien aussi gros et puis
selon celui qui était le plus demandées
par le public et peut se passer plus de
temps sur laquelle on voit encore ces
images des photos de cette époque c'est
assez surprenant de se dire que les
beatles ont commencé là-bas peut-être
parmi nos téléspectateurs se trouvent
certaines personnes qui ont pu découvrir
ce spectacle à cette époque en tout cas
ce soir au cirano dans les lieux mêmes
où se sont produits les beatles et le
50e anniversaire soirée hommage comment
va se dérouler la soirée il y aura un
concert un spectacle et une projection
ensuite alors on va commencer on a
choisi le mondial pourra faire prêter
avec un groupe qui devaient être plantés
en quartet avec une chanteuse américaine
donc ils vont jouer en live sur scène
comme à l'époque mais pas son gel vie le
répertoire des beatles pendant une heure
une heure et quart en plus quand ensuite
fait une petite pause de cinq minutes et
ensuite projection du film quatre
garçons dans le vent comme d'hab de
l'époque avec les people est-ce que
c'est complet ce qu'on a encore la
possibilité de dia sinon il reste
quelques places donc surtout
on va rester avec nous jusqu'à la fin du
journal et ensuite vous filer pour
versailles et ça débute aux alentours de
20h30 à 23h
merci d'avoir été en ligne avec nous
pour parler de ce concert événement
hommage au 50e anniversaire du premier
concert des beatles en france c'était à
versailles on reste dans le domaine de
la culture domaine de la culture
toujours avec bazar et bémol c'est un
trio originaire des yvelines qui sera
sur scène lui le 25 janvier à la
batterie à guyancourt on leur souhaite
bien évidemment le même succès qu'aux
beatles nous avons en tout cas rencontré
au cours de leur résidence artistique
qui précède le concert qui aura lieu le
25 janvier les images de jonathan vilma
n'est détiennent langue et le
commentaire d'aurélia double ici
shao ning et raphaël trois musiciens
talentueux trois amis aussi qui depuis
six ans forment le groupe bazar et bémol
leurs études achevées fin 2010 il décide
de faire de la musique une activité
professionnelle de la chanson française
swing tenté de multiples influences du
coup tout l'intérêt pour nous c'est de
sortir des clichés de la chanson
française pour essayer de faire quelque
chose un peu voilà métissé avec votre
style une vraie complémentarité entre
chaque instant dans la composition que
dans l'écriture des textes une plume
soigné que manier avec énergie et humour
ce trio festif
encore
on écrit tous les 3es mais on n'écrit
pas ensemble et après on fait les
arrangements ensemble et le texte en
tout cas la phase d'écriture le texte
est très important si on écrit juste
texte et la mélodie là pour mettre en
avant le texte et voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un travail d'écriture très
important sur la forme des mots qu'on va
utiliser on veut que ce soit le plus
politique possible leur première scène
ont lieu dans les rames du métro
parisien puis deux places publiques en
cabaret la mise en scène du spectacle
pour une nouvelle dimension une
transition s'opère un changement
d'échelle qui nécessite de porter un
nouveau regard sur le show après un
travail de résidence avec les studios de
la batterie à guyancourt ils se
produiront sur scène 25 janvier la
résidence est assez intense puisque
c'est sur trois jours trois quatre jours
on est vraiment tous les joueurs
beaucoup beaucoup d'idées comme alex
christophe et et femmes nous le disent
régulièrement c'est que voilà nous on
vous donne des idées vous les prenez
vous les mettez en place et puis après
vous vous réfléchissez et vous vous
prenez ça de là où cela vous éjecter
salah et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant en fait de recevoir cet
afflux d'informations en plus d'un autre
gars que notre metteur en scène
habituelle et triés et voir qu'est ce
qui peut être le mieux dans le spectacle
comme la sortie de leur premier album
est prévu pour début 2015
jusqu'au 2 mars la ville de guyancourt
propose de découvrir soixante années
d'évolution des oeuvres de gérard manot
nice est un artiste sculpteur qui a
travaillé pour la ville en 1984 il a
signé la place jacques brel au quartier
des garennes relie à domicile
la salle d'exposition de guyancourt
accueille jusqu'au 2 mars une
rétrospective des oeuvres du sculpteur
gérard manot ni en accord avec son
époque l'artiste s'imprègne des
évolutions techniques esthétiques et
sociétales en travaillant d'abord les
matériaux comme le plâtre le béton puis
l'acier et enfin l'aluminium le secteur
public s'intéresse particulièrement son
travail l'artiste est sollicité pour
réaliser des aménagements urbains et des
sculptures monumentales à guyancourt par
exemple on lui connaît la place jacques
brel du quartier des garennes créé en
1984 alors là la pièce la plus complète
la plus aboutie seuil en cours nous
c'est peut-être la raison ses missions
c'est le syndrome quand même tout seul
parce qu'elle avait pris des architectes
et des paysagistes laddh me suis
retrouvé tout seul j'ai tout conçu et
géré aussi l'ensemble je voulais
absolument qui est un point fort qui
était le bassin finalement la limite le
port fort pour moi c'est presque plus
d'un siècle après la sculpture pas
mettre la culture à l'arrivée pour faire
joli à la fin je me dis on va jeter
comme très content de la sphère lequel
elle très très bien intégré des
sculptures aux bijoux ou encore au
flacon de parfum l'exposition présente
les créations de mannoni dans sa
globalité et ses différentes
collaborations
pour terminer ce journal du 22 janvier
un mot d investiture de l'ue dei en vue
des municipales la formation centriste a
finalisé ses accords avec l'ump dans les
yvelines hier soir on notera à plaisir
que la maire sortante joséphine coleman
ce berger ump reçoit à l'investiture de
l'udps et y alors que le modem soutien
dans cette ville le ps on rappellera au
niveau national la création récente de
l'alternative censé marier les deux
formations centristes un mariage ponctué
de quelques infidélités et puis
également à voisins le bretonneux fin du
suspense alexandra rosetti ancienne
première adjointe du maire alexis piette
elle n'est pas soutenue par l'udps et y
elle se présentera donc sans étiquette
pas d'investiture mais un soutien de
l'ump et de l'udf à guyancourt à
montigny ou encore à versailles vous
allez découvrir la liste dans un instant
la liste de ses soutiens ump udi voilà
sur les listes attrape la verrière ou
encore versailles soutien des deux
formations s'étaient pas une investiture
mais un soutien des formations
politiques sachez aussi qu'à coignard il
n'y a pas de soutien pas d'investiture
ni de l'ump ni de lui dit henri paillet
maire sortant se présentera donc
visiblement comme divers droite enfin le
cas de maurepas ump ait eu des lions
décidé une investiture commune à une
liste d'union pierre leguérinel et
grégory gary astier ce sont deux
candidats qui se déchire depuis
plusieurs mois et c'est l'ump qui
précise dans un communiqué que sans
union les deux investiture seront
retirés et grégory gare estienne nous
précise que ces discussions des
discussions se déroulent actuellement il
réserve encore ses déclarations il se
fixe et s'exprimera pardon visiblement
deux mains dans ce journal et puis et
pierre leguérinel lui et dément le
retrait de l'investiture udi là aussi
pas de réaction plus détaillées pour le
moment le point complet ce sera donc
demain dans une nouvelle édition du
journal on se retrouvera en direct des
idées 18 heures votre soirée assure
téléphiles c'est avec le kiosque aurélia
de bissy dans un instant bonne soirée